2026년 5월 13일 수요일 미국 증시 유약입니다.
금일 미국 증시는 상승 마감했습니다.
예상치로 또는 인플레이션 지표에도 기술주 랠리가 이어지면서
S&P 지수는 사상 최고치를 경시했습니다.
인플레이션 반등 조짐으로 연준의 고금리 기조가
장기화될 수 있다는 우려가 커졌지만
시장은 기술주 강세에 더 크게 반응했습니다.
4월 생산자 물가 지수는 전월 대비 1.4% 급등해
4년 만에 가장 큰 월간 상승폭을 기록했습니다.
전년 대비로도 6% 오르며
2022년 이후 가장 높은 상승률을 보였습니다.
이번 물가 급등은 에너지 가격 상승이 주된 원인으로 꼽히지만
유가 상승의 여파가 경제 다른 부분으로 번지면서
인플레이션 압력이 확산되고 있음을 보여줬습니다.
이런 가운데 보승연은 콜린스 총재는
인플레이션 압력이 진정되고
금리 인상도 고려할 수 있다고 언급해
조기 금리 인하 기대를 더 낮췄습니다.
한편 미 상원은 케빈워시를 차기 연준 의장으로 최종 인준했습니다.
이번 인준은 수십 년 만에 가장 논란이 큰 연준 리더십 교체로 평가되며
향후 연준의 정치적 독립성에도 중대한 시험대가 될 전망입니다.
SM 표 비치 수는 0.6% 상승 마감했습니다.
엔비디아 젠 소방 CEO가
트럼프 대통령의 방중 경제에 대한 의견을 전했습니다.
기술주가 전체 상세에 이끌었습니다.
투자들은 황 CEO의 방중을 엔비디아가 중국 시장에서
AI 반도체 판매를 재개할 수 있는 긍정적인 신호로 받아들였습니다.
트럼프 대통령은 심핑 주석과 이틀간의 정상회담을 위해 베이징에 도착했습니다.
이번 회담에서는 중국 시장을 미국 기업들에게 더 개방하도록 요구하는 방안과
불안하게 이어지고 있는 무역 휴전 기조를 유지하는 문제가
주요 의제로 이어지고 있습니다.
벨벳 웰스의 클라크 밸리는
플랜티모라 파이낸셜의 짐 베어드는
이번 PPI 보선은 인플레이션 압력이 여전하다는 인식을 강화했고
연준의 금리 동결 기간이 더 길어질 수 있다는 전망에 힘을 실어줬다.
웰스파구의 게리슐로스버그는
PCE에 반영되는 PPI 항목들의 상승폭은
다른 부분의 압력에 비하면 완만한 수준이었다.
베어드의 로스메일필드는
반도체 주는 이제 시장의 다른 업종과는 다른 흐름을 보이고 있다.
투자들은 AI 수요를 바탕으로 반도체 성장세가 워낙 탄탄하기 때문에
유가나 금리 부담 같은 변수도 이 흐름을 쉽게 꺾지는 못한다고 보는 분위기다.
라고 전하였습니다.
2026년 5월 14일 목요일 주요 일정 새벽에
경제지표는
22시 30분 미국 4월 수입 물가지수
22시 30분 미국 신규 실업수당 청구 건수
22시 30분 미국 4월 소매 판매
23시 미국 3월 기업 재고
23시 15분 연준 슈미드 총재
23시 30분 미국 EIA 천연가스 재고
02시 미국 활맥 총재가 예정되어 있습니다.